[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa este es el
magazine de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias e historias de
nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy
la invasión rusa a ucrania desató un
terremoto geopolítico eeuu se envió a
una delegación a hablar con funcionarios
del gobierno de nicolás maduro en
caracas y logró la liberación de dos
estadounidenses que habían sido
detenidos aunque aún se desconoce a
cambio de que además yo white él nombró
a colombia vecino de venezuela como
aliado estratégico por fuera de la otan
y seguimos hablando de venezuela pero de
la crisis económica que ha llevado a
menores de edad a empezar a trabajar
para ayudar a sus padres les contamos
sus historias de la mano de nuestra
corresponsal en la capital venezolana
y gabriel boric asumió como presidente
de chile se trata del mandatario más a
la izquierda desde salvador allende les
mostramos el país que recibe
y vamos de inmediato con nuestra
historia principal la invasión rusa
ucrania desató un sismo geopolítico el
presidente estadounidense joe biden
envió una delegación a caracas a hablar
con funcionarios del gobierno de nicolás
maduro a quien en el pasado ha
calificado de dictador la casa blanca
confirmó que en el encuentro se buscó
garantizar los suministros de energía
sin aclarar si eso implica un eventual
levantamiento de las sanciones a las
importaciones de petróleo venezolano
efectivas desde 2019 cuando el entonces
presidente estadounidense donald trump
reconoció al líder opositor juan guaidó
como el presidente legítimo de venezuela
pero lo cierto es que cuatro días
después de la reunión bailén impuso un
veto de las importaciones de petróleo
ruso y dos ciudadanos estadounidenses
que estaban presos en caracas fueron
liberados mientras que maduro dijo que
retomaría las conversaciones con la
oposición en mexico coincidencia veamos
más en el siguiente informe
después del embargo decretado sobre las
importaciones de petróleo y gas de rusia
eeuu mira a venezuela para satisfacer
sus necesidades energéticas el
presidente nicolás maduro recibió una
delegación de la unión americana en
caracas el régimen es el aliado más
cercano de rusia en américa del sur
yo podría calificar la de respetuosa
cordial
muy diplomática
me pareció muy importante
poder cara a cara
conversar temas de máximo interés
de venezuela un gran interés financiero
antes del embargo impuesto en abril de
2019 las exportaciones de petróleo hacia
eeuu le representaban a venezuela el 96
por ciento de sus ingresos pero además
del asunto de la seguridad energética de
la unión americana la suerte de los
detenidos estadounidenses fue también
abordada tras este encuentro el
presidente joe biden anunció la
liberación de dos ciudadanos
estadounidenses dos estadounidenses que
fueron detenidos injustamente en
venezuela podrán abrazar de nuevo a sus
familias traemos de vuelta a gustavo
cárdenas y jorge alberto fernández a
casa otra evidencia del acercamiento
entre los dos países que rompieron
relaciones diplomáticas en 2019 luego de
que el entonces presidente de donald
trump reconociera a juan guaidó como
presidente legítimo de venezuela es que
maduro dijo que estaba listo para
retomar las conversaciones con la
oposición en mexico mesa de diálogo de
la que se levantó en 2021 al darse a
conocer la extradición de su aliado el
empresario colombiano álex up desde cabo
verde a miami acusado de lavado de
dinero
entre tanto vaivén realizó otro
movimiento estratégico recibió al
presidente colombiano iván duque en la
casa blanca y nombró a el país como
aliado por fuera de la otan en esta
categoría se encuentran países como
australia egipto e israel y por américa
sólo otros dos argentina que fue añadida
en
1998 brasil y ahora colombia
pero qué significa esto si bien no
contempla una cláusula de defensa mutua
como con los otros miembros de la
alianza trasatlántica si representa
acceso a equipo militar y municiones
estadounidenses almacenamiento en
colombia' de equipos que hagan parte de
sus reservas de guerra y participación
en actividades contra terroristas entre
otros que en la coyuntura actual podría
no ser un simple acto simbólico si
vladimir putin continúa expandiéndose
y cambiamos de tema pero sigamos en
venezuela porque la difícil situación
económica que atraviesa ha llevado a los
menores de edad a trabajar informalmente
por supuesto como medio de subsistencia
debido a la pandemia y el cierre de las
escuelas aumentó considerablemente la
presencia de niños y adolescentes que
realizan oficios para ayudar a sus
padres con los gastos básicos nos cuenta
más nuestra corresponsal en caracas
daniela zambrano ya tener quevedo
regresa de la escuela y prepara una
improvisada barbería a las puertas de su
casa un oficio que aprendió de su tío a
los 12 años por curiosidad pero que
luego ejerció por necesidad en medio de
la pandemia en ese tiempo mi hermano
tuvimos trabajo y fue que decidí hacer
esto para comprar mis cosas porque de
verdad no necesitaba tienen el control
habito con la mitad
por cada corte es jack nerd percibe 4
dólares más de dos sueldos mínimos en
venezuela un monto que representa el
doble de lo que mensualmente ganaba su
mamá y que no alcanza para la
alimentación básica familiar pues me
compro mis cosas personales mi
ropa zapatos y cuando puedo lo ayudo en
otro barrio popular de caracas chirla y
carranza de 16 años trabaja como niñera
los 5 dólares que gana semanales
cuidando a una bebé le sirven para
comprar sus artículos de higiene
personal yo necesitaba tener platica
para comprar las cosas personal de
nosotros de ese champú afectador a
hisopo
placentaria desde hace más de 13 años no
existen estadísticas oficiales sobre el
trabajo infantil en venezuela sin
embargo algunas ongs calculan que ha ido
en aumento sobre todo desde que llegó la
pandemia siendo la mendicidad el trabajo
doméstico y las ventas ambulantes en sus
oficios más comunes a pesar de no tener
dato oficial y consolidada desagregada
actualizado y confiable si alertamos
sobre los incrementos los factores de
riesgo donde los niños los adolescentes
pueden ver el trabajo como una opción de
supervivencia por ley y jacques nerd
pese a que comenzaron una vida laboral a
temprana edad cuentan con la supervisión
de sus representantes no obstante se
queda para alerta que existen otros
menores que están haciendo trabajos
nocivos como la minería ilegal o el
transporte de gasolina porque se les
asocia con una mano de obra económica
[Música]
y vamos a méxico para revisar otras
noticias de las américas esta semana el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
calificó de injerencistas y borregos a
los diputados del parlamento europeo en
respuesta a una resolución que aprobaron
en rechazo a los asesinatos de
periodistas en el país norteamericano y
en la que pedían más acciones al
mandatario para detener ese flagelo
la cámara de diputados de argentina
aprobó el acuerdo con el fondo monetario
internacional
alcanzado por el presidente alberto
fernández para refinanciar la deuda de
45 mil millones de dólares adquirida por
el gobierno anterior en de mauricio
macri mientras los diputados discutían
al respecto en las afueras del congreso
se registraron manifestaciones que
terminaron en disturbios la medida pasa
ahora al senado
los legisladores del estado de la
florida aprobaron un proyecto de ley
respaldado por los republicanos que
prohíbe la discusión en las aulas sobre
la orientación sexual y la identidad de
género pese a las protestas
estudiantiles que tacharon la medida
como discriminatoria
y el presidente de guatemala alejandro
giammattei aseguró que vetaría el
proyecto de ley que busca aumentar las
penas por aborto y prohibir el
matrimonio entre personas del mismo sexo
el anuncio llega a tan solo dos días
después de que celebrara la aprobación
del mismo en el legislativo
gabriel boric ha asumido como el nuevo
presidente de chile se trata del
gobierno más a la izquierda desde el de
salvador allende el ex líder estudiantil
nombró al gabinete más feminista de la
historia del país con más mujeres que
hombres y por primera vez con una
ministra del interior tiene el reto de
satisfacer las demandas ciudadanas de
mejor salud mejor educación y acceso a
pensiones en un momento de alto
endeudamiento fiscal y con un congreso
muy dividido también enfrenta el desafío
de acompañar el proceso constituyente
que dibuja un nuevo mapa social y
político en el país nuestra corresponsal
en santiago patricia luna entrevistó a
tres ciudadanos que nos contaron las
expectativas que tienen con el nuevo
mandatario
mujeres al poder en chile gabriel boric
empieza una nueva etapa como presidente
y todas las ministras y mujeres fuertes
de su futuro gabinete se han dispuesto a
llevar la lucha no solo a los despachos
sino también a las calles emilia
sneijder quien será la primera diputada
transitoria del país encabezó la ola del
feminismo de las universidades de 2018 y
ahora siendo gobierno espera que se
concreten políticas de aborto libre y
educación sexual integral esta va a ser
un gobierno muy importante para las
mujeres y las diversidades sexuales
porque ya el gobierno ha tenido jornadas
de trabajo para transversalizar la
perspectiva de género en todas las
políticas públicas laborales económicas
educativas sanitarias el mundo
empresarial ha visto con buenos ojos el
programa más moderado de boris y a la
designación de su ministro de hacienda
mario marcel un economista con
credibilidad sin embargo para
empresarios como guillermo tag él hay
otros aspectos a considerar el factor de
incertidumbre mayor es sin duda
lo que pase durante el año 2022 con el
epílogo de la convención constituyente
eso es lo que tiene detenido en el mundo
de inversiones en muchas industrias y
mientras no se clarifique eso por qué
tipo de organización política social
económica vamos a tener es difícil que
volvamos a tener una actividad económica
normal las expectativas en todos los
sectores sociales son elevadas en este
barrio a las afueras de santiago de
población obrera como el que eligió el
nuevo presidente para vivir mirta guzmán
su hermana su hijo y la novia de éste no
esconden su entusiasmo por lo que se
viene muchísima esperanza me llega a dar
miedo toda la esperanza que él influye
yo de repente hablo con mis alumnos y
todos tienen como mucha esperanza de que
pues se puedan cambiar muchas cosas que
son muy injustas que hay en chile las
pensiones la salud la educación sistema
de la vivienda
diversidad feminismo endeudamiento
necesidad de inversión cambios sociales
las ecuaciones que se presentan ante el
nuevo gobierno de boris no tienen
resultados
los distintos sectores del país están
esperando con ansia este cambio de
mirada que se inaugura en chile
y sigamos en chile- para el cierre esta
semana se celebraron además las primeras
bodas entre personas del mismo sexo tras
la entrada en vigor de la ley de
matrimonio igualitario promulgada por
sebastián piñera en diciembre de 2021 la
legislación que vio la luz tras años de
debates en el congreso permite la
afiliación y la adopción de niños por
parte de parejas del mismo sexo antes
sólo existía un acuerdo de unión civil
que no reconocía enteramente los
derechos y deberes de las parejas
diversas
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de aquí américa en la producción estuvo
joan y agudelo pueden ver esta emisión y
las anteriores en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom y pueden seguirme en
redes sociales en la dirección que ven
en sus pantallas para más información de
nuestro continente siguen viendo
france24
[Música]
reporteros